Bienvenidos a este espacio de France 24
dedicado a las noticias más destacadas
de la economía internacional nos
acompaña para ello Jorge Hurtado Qué tal
Cómo estás Jorge le propongo que
empecemos esta edición hablando de la
ley que firmó el gobernador de Florida
para acabar con el llamado autogobierno
de los parques Disney en Orlando hay que
entender cómo funcionan estos distritos
y para ello te quería contar y les
quería contar también a ustedes que el
distrito especial de ready es un
gobierno privado y controlado por Disney
World que Data desde 1967 y que le
permite brindar servicio gubernamentales
Como urbanizar la protección contra
incendios los servicios públicos e
inclusive construir infraestructura en
los años 60 esa zona estaba formada por
terrenos agrícolas sin explotar y
algunos pantanos el empresario Walt
Disney pidió un estatus impositivo
especial junto al derecho de administrar
y hacer inversiones para brindar en
infraestructura y así desarrollar su
proyecto de entretenimiento desde
entonces se construyeron los parques
temáticos y el desarrollo turístico por
supuesto trajo consigo bajo ese Distrito
especial Disney actualmente controla 110
kilómetros cuadrados entre los condados
de osiola y Orange las ciudades de The
Lake y Lake Buenavista tiene cuatro
parques temáticos dos acuáticos
gestionan 175 millas de carreteras 67
millas de vías navegables y 40.000
habitaciones de hotel Asimismo están a
cargo de los servicios básicos de la
ciudad como el control contra incendios
entre otros incluso tiene la capacidad
de emitir bonos Y por qué la gobernación
de Florida quiere acabar ahora con este
estatus especial Bueno aunque el
gobernador ronde santis afirma que busca
acabar con el Imperio corporativo como
le llama y los beneficios Fiscales de
Disney detrás de ello existe una disputa
después de que el gigante del
entretenimiento se declarara en contra
de su polémica política conocida como no
digas gay que prohibía a las
instrucciones sobre orientación sexual e
identidad de género hasta el tercer
grado en las escuelas conversamos antes
con María Isabel puerta una profesora de
ciencias políticas y habitantes de la
zona le preguntamos qué tan importante
es Disney para su comunidad y cuáles son
los temores entre los habitantes de
estas ciudades
es uno de los más importantes
empleadores de la de la zona de la
región vamos a hablar de Orlando y de
los municipios aledaños que son los
suburbios eh muchos de nosotros sino
conocemos a alguien que trabaja en
Disney estamos conectados yo por ejemplo
soy profesora tengo montones estudiantes
que que no solamente son trabajadores de
Disney sino que hay convenios con las
universidades al menos en una de las
universidades donde yo doy clases hay un
convenio con Disney o donde tenemos
estudiantes tanto para inglés
hotelería turismo es decir aquí hay unas
alianzas desde el punto de vista de la
comunidad que son tremendas y y bueno
eso es parte del problema que aquí se
está posiblemente lesionando un una
relación que Data de décadas
y Jorge bajo este nuevo estatuto no sin
este autogobernación Disney tendrá que
informar entendemos al Estado de sus
presupuestos de sus proyectos hay
muchísimos cambios Bueno también se
eliminan por ejemplo las extensiones de
revisión y aprobaciones regulatorias
estatales para Disney según la
gobernación de Florida esta medida
asegura que la deuda municipal de Disney
será pagada por la compañía pero los
propietarios inmobiliarios de la zona se
preparan para enfrentarse a un
incremento de un 20% aproximadamente de
sus impuestos sobre esto opinó nuestra
invitada yo tengo una hipoteca Que ya
sube cada año normalmente naturalmente
no por una circunstancia como esta Pero
además en la comunidad donde yo vivo hay
mucha gente que compra vivienda con
inversión por qué porque esto es una
zona turística y la gente compra casas
apartamentos
para alquilarlo por el turismo Entonces
si esto
ya Florida y Florida Central en concreto
está viviendo un momento difícil desde
el punto de vista del del costo de la
vivienda no solamente para quienes
compramos sino para la gente que vive
alquilada yo misma tuve que comprar
porque los alquileres eran tan elevados
que no valía la pena era preferible
comprar Pero entonces si los alquileres
van a subir Aquí vamos a llegar un
momento en que muchos de mis vecinos que
son Realmente casas para alquilar van a
quedar desocupadas porque la gente no va
a poder y eso va a ser un problema eso
va a ser otro tipo de crisis en punto de
vista del sector móvil hasta ahora
Disney respondió que se ajustaría a la
nueva medida de Florida la empresa es el
mayor empleador del estado con unos
80.000 contratos y alimenta una
industria turística que genera 75 mil
millones de dólares anuales Jorge bueno
se nos acaba el tiempo pero muchísimas
gracias por la explicación de una
situación de la que muchos me incluyo
seguramente no teníamos conocimiento nos
vemos en la próxima a ustedes Muchísimas
gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros